اساطير اسي ميلان ينعن
ومشجع صيني يطارد ميسي من اجل سيلفي
ومحمد هنيدي يتحدى هالاند في صوره
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ودع العديد من لاعبي ومدربي اي سي ميلان
السابقين مالك النادي السابق ورئيس وزراء
ايطاليا الاسبق سيلفيو بيرلس كول اثر وفيه
عن عمر يناهز 86 عاما ويعد
رؤساء انديه كره القدم الايطاليه على مر
التاريخ من بين المعلقين على وفاه الرئيس
الراحل
الذي كتب في تغريده على تويتر لا توجد
كلمات كافيه لتشهد على التقدير والامتنان
اما المدرب كارلو انشيلوتي فكتب حزن اليوم
لا يمحو لحظات السعيده التي قضيناها معا
خبرنا التالي عن واحده من اغلى صور
السيلفي في العالم ماديا ومعنويا ووقتا
كذلك مشجعا صيني يدعى لي يوهان قضى ساعات
طويله من الانتظار في غرفه فندق باهظه
الثمن ومطارده مرهقه كل هذا من اجل صوره
سيلفي مع ميسي غير واضحه القصه بدات عندما
علم الشاب بزياره ميسي الى بلاده رفقه
منتخب الارجنتين حاول اختراق الحشود في
استقبال البرغوث لكنه لم ينجح ثم قرر ان
يحجز غرفه في نفس فندق اقامه ميسي فاذا ان
الامن منعه من التنقل بالحريه هذه المره
جاءت فرصته اخيرا عندما راى حافله الفريق
تتوجه من الفندق في طريقها الى حصه
تدريبيه توجت المطارده اخيرا بسلف معمس من
بعيد
تيرى الفنان المصري محمد هنيدي من الحكام
بعد فوز الاهلي بدوري ابطال افريقيا ونشر
صوره للنادي القاهري عبر فيسبوك وكتب
هنادي مبروك للاهلي سلطان افريقيا وهارد
لك للحكام وكان الاهلي قد توجد باللقب
الافريقي على حساب الوداد المغربي هنيدي
اكتفي بذلك بل وضع الصوره لها معلقا وده
يتعامل معه في كنايه عن مشاركه الفريقين
في مونديال الانديه مانشستر سيتي فريق
هالاند والاهلي فريقه هنادي
تجاهل نجوم مانشستر سيتي الانجليزي حفل
العشاء الذي اعده لهم النادي في احد
المطاعم الفاخره بمدينه مانشستر بعد
التتويج بلقب دوري ابطال اوروبا صحيفه
كشفت عن ان ثلاثه لاعبين فقط من هجوم
مانشستر سيتي تمكنوا من حضور العشاء
الاحتفالي مع اعضاء الطاقم الفني والاداري
الصحيفه اكدت بان باقي النجوم سافروا على
متن طائره خاصه للاحتفال في الشواطئ مدينه
ابيزا الاسبانيه وكان مانشستر سيتي نجح في
خطف اللقب على حساب انتر ميلان ايطالي في
اسطنبول
[موسيقى]